Michael we it feels like we're on the
cusp of entering this new phase of the
war how are both sides preparing yes
they are preparing for a new phase I
mean the Russians have actually pulled
back a bit they were pushing all around
the uh the the border of the of the area
that was contested that's about a
thousand kilometers and they were
pushing in the north they were pushing a
bit in the South but they've stopped
pushing now apart from back which is a
story all of its own they've stopped
pushing and they're digging in they're
digging in particularly in the South
um because that's obviously where they
expect some sort of a attack to come and
south of zaparisia
um that area from zapparesia down to
Crimea that clearly is where they think
the ukrainians will do something because
they're defensive in that area from
zaprasia to Melita pole are really thick
really Fierce and it looks as if they
might even be preparing to withdraw some
troops from around Curson from the
Eastern Bank of the NEPA River because
they don't want those troops to get cut
off if the ukrainians come directly
south and they may want to to uh
concentrate them more in an area of a
breakthrough so the Russian Behavior
Behavior indicates they think the
ukrainians will come southwards but the
ukrainians will want to surprise them
they'll want to surprise us all and I
suspect we might see some distraction
operations we might see some diversions
before we work out exactly how this
offensive is going to play out in the
coming weeks and meanwhile while while
the fighting has been happening because
of the weather it's been an opportunity
for Ukraine to stock up on on weapons
what have both sides got essentially
before we Embark again yes I mean I
think the Russians are holding back a
certain amount of heavy metal the
certain amount of their armor because
they'll need to bring it in at some
point when the Ukrainian attack Begins
the ukrainians we know have got
according to Nato they've got 98 of all
of the weapons that the NATO allies
promised them and so that really is his
main battle tanks are really important
so we know that the ukrainians have got
uh 230 main Western main battle tanks
that's a leopard tank there which is the
one that they really want they've got
some challenges as well and some other
French tanks they Max tens but that's
really important but also they've got
over 1500 fighting Vehicles armored
fighting Vehicles so the various armored
vehicles fighting Vehicles armored
personnel carriers and these have got to
go with the tanks because the tanks have
to operate with other vehicles with the
Infantry with the artilleries it's got
to be a combined package to work
properly this is what the Russians
aren't very good at doing the ukrainians
have put together what looks like a
western armored Brigade and they may
have that figure of 230 tanks is a magic
number because if they've got 200 tanks
they've got enough for two armored
brigades if they've got 1500 armored
vehicles to go with them the question is
two armor brigades would be very
powerful units have they organized them
well enough have they integrated them
well enough because they're not used to
doing this either so in the limited time
available have they been able to
integrate their forces to real effect
well we'll find out as and when they
start to use them of course it is all
dependent on the weather when do we
think this new phase might begin
um quite soon I keep saying that that
map that hasn't changed for months will
start to change when the weather changes
and this is the Outlook now and we'll
keep our eye on the weather because the
ground is drying out the temperatures
Rising towards 18 19 20. this is for the
next few days it's been very wet
recently because that's the Ukrainian
spring but spring becomes summer very
quickly in Ukraine when the ground dries
out then I think we'll start to see the
beginnings of this because the
ukrainians can't use their tanks if if
they're Road bound that's the way to
lose them they've got to be able to get
to get them on a broad front across the
ground and actually make a big impact
across a fairly wide area these some of
these tanks are 70 tons you can't drive
a 70 ton tank over soft ground so they
have to wait for the weather to change
but the weather is changing and for all
of those who are wondering when this
offensive will start I say keep your eye
on the weather forecast okay thanks very
much